hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es wieder ein basic
rezept und zwar mache ich eine
italienische buttercreme die besteht aus
eiweiß und dotter und diese eiweiß masse
wird mit zucker etwas also dies nicht
mehr weil der zuckerwert zu zucker sirup
aufgekocht und kommt ganz heiß dann zum
eiweiß mit dazu das heißt dann müsste
keine angst haben dass sie irgendwie
weiß verwendet und die buttercreme hat
viel fett hat auch viel zucker schmeckt
aber nicht zu süß also nicht dass jetzt
denkt das ist eine super fettige super
süße creme sondern sie hebt einfach
richtig schönen geschmack und markante
gut aromatisieren mit verschiedenen
fruchtpüree soder mit aromen mit
zitronen orangen schale mit haselnuss
passten und so weiter also dieses
wirklich sehr variationsreich und ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal kurz die
zutaten ganz wichtig ist aber dass ihr
ein zucker thermometer benutzt denn wir
müssen gleich den zuckersirup aufkochen
und damit der einfach die richtige
konsistenz hat also weder zu flüssig
noch zu fest wird oder hat so
dickflüssig wird muss er eben mit einem
zucker thermometer kontrolliert werden
hier stehen schon mal einen zutaten
ich habe hier acht große weiße also von
eiern größe l das sind ungefähr 350
gramm also falls ihr kleinerer benutzt
müsste es einfach abwiegen eine prise
salz 450 gramm zucker 125 milliliter
wasser und hier habe ich 500 gramm
butter de ist bereits zimmer waren
jetzt müssen wir zuerst den zucker sirup
herstellen
dafür gebe ich zucker und wasser in
meinem kopf
da stelle ich den herd ein auf höchste
stufe und sobald es anfängt zu kochen
stecke ich dann auch gleich dass zucker
thermometer rein und dann fange ich erst
an das eiweiß steif zu schlagen wenn wir
mal das eiweiß zu lange rührt dann wird
es irgendwann so trocken und das möchte
ich nicht
jetzt kocht sehr zuckersirup jetzt gebe
ich das thermometer mit rein und ich auf
dem thermometer da seht ihr hier die
temperaturanzeige und ich möchte jetzt
200 bis 300 möchte 218 grad und es ist
hierbei softball also hier drüben hab
ich grad celsius hier habe ich
fahrenheit und hier jetzt eben software
ein
jetzt seht ihr auch wie das buch
blättert jetzt kann ich hier drüben
schon mal das eiweiß und das salz in die
rührschüssel geben
und fangen einfach schon mal an das
steif zu schlagen uns was so auf mittel
hoher stufe
damit einfach nicht zu schnell fährt
so sollte der schnee aussehen also
richtig fest
und jetzt gebe ich den heißen
zuckersirup rein dann ist er ganz
vorsichtig sein dass wirklich sehr heiß
jetzt ist die schüssel auch von außen
wirklich daheim und ihr müsst ihr jetzt
so lange röhren dieser eismasse dieter
kempf kalt wird also bis sie wieder
raumtemperatur angenommen hat es kann
wirklich so etwa 20 minuten dauern
ich hatte zwischendurch geschissen auch
in eiswasser stellen damit eben auch die
schiffe wieder kalt wird und dann komme
ich die gleichen ich habe jetzt hier die
kahlschlag im eiweiß masse und ich habe
übrigens die eismasse in einem kalten in
der calle schüssel umgefüllt weil
einfach die schlüssel viel zu heiß war
habe es kurz ungefüllten einfach weiter
rühren lassen
und hier habe ich bereits die butter
schön schaumig geschlagen luftig
geschlagen
das dürft ihr übrigens mit dem
schneebesen nur machen wenn die butter
wirklich zimmer war mit also wenn es
sehr weich ist und jetzt wird die kalte
schneemasse einfach unter die butter
masse gehoben
und ihr bekommt übrigens alles aus dem
schneebesen raus wenn ihr einfach eure
hände benutzt also dem teig schreiber
kommt man da einfach nicht so gut rein
einfach die hände benutzen
die creme ist fertig und herausgekommen
ist ein richtig schönes softer creme
auch ziemlich finne muss von der textur
her
natürlich muss man jetzt noch ein
bisschen kühl stellen also ich würde
jetzt noch zehn minuten kühl stellen
bevor ich jetzt dort damit befüllen
ihr könnt die creme zu lassen oder ihr
könnt noch etwas vanille takt hinzufügen
etwas zitronenschale andere aromen gerne
auch etwas fruchtpüree und könnt somit
die creme verfeinern und die eignet sich
übrigens auch hervorragend unter von
dort die löst nämlich denn von dort
nicht auf weil es einfach aus fett und
zucker und eiweiß besteht und einfach
nicht zu feucht ist
deswegen ist es neben der garage auch
eine ideale von land grundlage also ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen
ihr müsst auf jeden fall die einzelnen
schritte ganz genau beachten damit er
eben nichts schief läuft und dann habt
ihr wirklich eine richtig leckere schöne
usa twitter creme und wenn sie fest also
wenn sie kalt wird im kühlschrank wird
sie übrigens wieder sehr fest durch den
butter anteil also viel spaß beim
nachmachen das rezept gibt es auch
cellestis blog.de bis zum nächsten mal